robert spencer what do you make of the
fbi
and the justice department chasing
parents who oppose vaccine mandates as
domestic terrorists instead of the real
terrorists who want to bring down this
country
this is something that's been in the
offing for 10 years now
10 years ago the obama administration
scrubbed all mention of islam and jihad
from counter-terror training and they
named the counter-terror program
countering violent extremism
at that time i don't think it was a
coincidence the southern poverty law
center the far left hate propaganda
group started to label me and others who
opposed jihad violence and sharia
oppression of women as extremists and
now we see what the agenda is here that
the biden administration the biden
justice department
they are labeling decent law-abiding
loyal americans as extremists in order
ultimately to silence and even
criminalize
opposition to their agenda
and that's one of the things that we see
happening with this labeling of people
who are protesting at school board
meetings domestic terrorists
it's just as ridiculous as calling me
and others extremists and it's just as
insidious and ultimately the end game is
to make it so that only
the left's point of view can be voiced
in the united states we're rapidly
getting there and we can only hope
something will change before the freedom
of speech is destroyed entirely